the graph of y is equal to the absolute
value of x is reflected across the
x-axis and then compressed vertically by
a factor of eight-thirds what is the
equation of the new graph
all right so let's think about this step
by step
so if i start and i'm just going to draw
some quick hand drawn sketches here
so that's my x-axis
that is my y-axis and if we're talking
about
the graph of
y is equal to the absolute value of x
that looks like this
in the first quadrant it looks like y
equals x
and in
the second quadrant it looks like y
equals negative x because the absolute
value of a negative number is its
opposite
so let me make it look a little bit more
symmetric than that
so it looks something
something
like that that's what the graph of y is
equal to the absolute value of x looks
like
now they're asking us to do what amounts
to two different transformations
the first one is they want to reflect it
they want to reflect across the x-axis
so they want us to flip it across the
x-axis like this so instead
it looks like this
so that graph
that equation that describes this graph
well this is going to be the opposite
whatever y you were getting on this
orange graph you're going to get the
negative of that so you're going to get
y is equal to the negative of the
absolute value of x
and if this doesn't make intuitive sense
to you try it out
in the orange graph
when x is equal to let's say 2 well the
absolute value of 2 is 2. the absolute
value of negative 2 is 2. but now we
want to take the absolute value but then
take the negative of it this thing stays
non-positive the entire time so the
absolute value of 2 is 2 but we want the
opposite of that we want negative 2.
absolute value of negative 2 is 2 but we
want the opposite of that
but they didn't ask us to just reflect
across the x-axis they then want us to
compress vertically by a factor of 8
thirds so let's think about this a
little bit compress vertically by a
factor of eight-thirds
so they said stretch vertically by a
factor of eight-thirds then i would just
multiply this by eight-thirds and
sometimes it's helpful to think of this
in terms of a mixed number eight-thirds
is the same thing as two
and two thirds so if you were to stretch
by two and two thirds you would get
taller you would look something
you would
it would get something like this but if
you are compressing
then it's going to look something like
this if you're compressing vertically
you can think about it as being
stretched
horizontally
so if you're compressing by a factor you
should multiply by the reciprocal of
that factor think about it if you're
compressing by three you would multiply
by one third so if you're compressing
vertically by eight thirds well that
means whatever y you would have gotten
you multiply that times the reciprocal
of eight thirds or you could another way
you could think about you could divide
that by 8 3.
so
if we want to get if we want to get this
thing right over here
this is going to be y is equal to
the negative absolute value of x and
since we're compressing by eight thirds
we would divide that by eight thirds or
another way to think about it dividing
by eight thirds is the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so
negative three eighths times the
absolute value of x
and when we look at our choices we see
that it is
that choice
right over there and i really want to
stress this point because i think it can
get a little bit confusing
the reason why i multiplied that by the
reciprocal it was saying compressing
vertically if we said stretching
vertically we would just multiply by
eight thirds but since we're compressing
we would divide by eight thirds or
multiply by its reciprocal